[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 1er décembre
voici les titres de l'actualité locale
le début aujourd'hui d'une campagne de
dépistage aux copies de 10,9 au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines jusqu'à demain vous pourrez y
effectuer gratuitement et sur
rendez-vous un test anti génie qui livre
son verdict en 30 minutes et deux mille
prélèvements sont prévues sur place
c'est un secteur lourdement touché par
la crise sanitaire puis économique
l'industrie qui représente 20 % de
l'emploi salarié dans le département est
soutenue et des plans de relance de
l'état et de la région ile de france ont
déjà été annoncés on en parle avec
sophie primas sénatrice l ère des
yvelines et puis c'est la dernière
grande étape du chantier de la rd 30
ouverture de la passerelle piétons vélos
au niveau du bois de la crâne à plaisir
l édifice a été installé la nuit
dernière
nous reviendrons également tout à
l'heure sur la visite de jean castex
dans les yvelines le premier ministre
était hier à trappes
[Musique]
le vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines c'est donc de nouveau
transformé en un centre de dépistage
pour deux jours cette fois ci il s'agit
de tests antigénique ils sont
accessibles à tous une nouvelle
organisation a été pensée sur place pour
réduire le temps d'attenté fluidifier le
passage le reportage de justin brasey
des tests antigénique accessible à tous
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
une deuxième opération de dépistage
massive sur deux jours les mardi 1er et
mercredi 2 décembre pour augmenter la
sécurité sanitaire
c'est de casser la chaîne de propagation
des quelqu'un sait si l'aïe ne se
comporte plus la même façon il réduit
ses contacts sociaux suivaient la phase
test qu'aux vide
j'ai reçu un message de sur facebook
parce que je connais je suivais site est
ce que y
donc j'ai inscrit ce dr libre qui dit
nouvelle opération d'une nouvelle
organisation
les tests sont disponibles gratuitement
et sans ordonnance les personnes
volontaires se font tester une à une et
sont ensuite dirigé vers une salle
d'attentes
les résultats sont disponibles en 15
minutes pour fluidifier le passage les
rendez vous sont à prendre via la
plateforme d'octo libre c'est très
simple moi j'ai été informée par ma
commune j'ai eu un lien et puis comme je
l'avais jamais été inscrite sur
d'autolib il a fallu que je crée mon
compte et ensuite les questions sont
posées ont rempli et puis on a
immédiatement la validation sur le
téléphone une répétition du futur
vaccinodromes qui se tiendra au
vélodrome objectif améliorer encore
l'organisation et être fin prêt à partir
de janvier pour de potentiels vaccin ça
nous permet de préparer l'opération
quand même forte de janvier je pense
c'est entre janvier et février on aura
certainement peut avoir
près de cent mille personnes qu'il
faudra vacciner dans des conditions très
rapide avec des médecins des pharmaciens
dans la meilleure condition sanitaire
une organisation la plus impeccable
possible lors de la première opération
en septembre dernier près de 2000
personnes se sont fait tester depuis la
semaine dernière également une vaste
campagne de dépistage a démarré dans les
lycées franciliens c'est à l'initiative
de la région et de l'agencé régionale de
santé d'île de france
quatre établissements sont concernés
dans les yvelines dont jules ferry à
versailles le 27 novembre dernier
environ 250 tests antigénique ont été
réalisés avec des lycéens et personnels
volontaires
cette démarche expérimentale vise à
préparer une action de dépistage
généralisé dans les lycées qui aura lieu
après les fêtes de fin d'année les
propos recueillis sur place par bixente
n'a rien senti steban c'était une
démarche sur laquelle vont se porter
volontaire parce que on se rend compte
qu'il ya quand même une inquiétude de la
part des étudiants de la part des
personnels sur cette question de
l'accueil vide et donc c'était
l'occasion de proposer
un dispositif qui permet de rassurer
tout le monde l'idée c'est de pouvoir
lancer une un dépistage massif de tous
les personnels et les élèves qui sont
volontaires pour pouvoir venir se faire
dépister par test antigénique après les
vacances scolaires après toute cette
période épidémique on a connu pour voir
un petit peu qu'elle ait la circulation
du virus
nous relations hier d'ailleurs dans ce
journal les dernières données du coc vie
de 19 dans le département des chiffres
épidémie qui baisse c'est une bonne
chose mais la prudence reste de mise
écoute et on est maintenant à peu près
en incidence à 125 cas pour 100000
habitants sur une positivité à 13,5 pour
cent
donc ça reste toujours élevé mais ça va
nettement mieux par rapport à ce qu'on a
rencontrés on est quand même toujours un
petit peu au dessus des taux d'incidence
et de positivité de la région donc il
faut rester vigilant la pression sur le
système de santé diminue également on a
un taux d'occupation des lits drea qui
est à 74 %
aujourd'hui donc c'est toujours assez
important mais ça va quand même mieux
nettement mieux
également dans l'actualité trois
ministres dont jean castex attrape irles
1,10 au programme visite de l'entreprise
connaît qui est spécialisé dans les
ascenseurs avec un objectif pour ce
déplacement promouvoir l'apprentissage
au travers du nouveau plan un jeune une
solution sur place astri bergère patrick
jacques de dixmude et les honneurs
sinoquet le premier ministre jean castex
était hier à trappes pour promouvoir
l'apprentissage avec la ministre du
travail
elisabeth bornes et la ministre déléguée
auprès de la ministre de la cohésion du
territoire nadia et il s'est rendu dans
l'entreprise connaît l'un des leaders
dans le secteur des ascenseurs qui
dispose d'un centre de formation
continue c'est pas tous les jours qu'on
a la visite d'un premier ministre un
attrape visitant une très belle
entreprise le territoire connaît surtout
pour promouvoir l'apprentissage c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de dispositifs
qui existent à destination de nos jeunes
dont les entreprises sont souvent pas
toujours parfaitement au courant et
c'est vrai qu'il faut que les
entreprises les mobiles
parce que sa lutte contre le chômage
d'une population les jeunes qui sont
durement impactée par la crise sanitaire
pour répondre aux difficultés des jeunes
le gouvernement a lancé l'été dernier
en plus de la réforme de l'apprentissage
de 2018 le plomb un jeune une solution
ce plan se traduit par des aides à
l'embauché des aides financières ou
encore des formations
cette visite à trappes a aussi été
l'occasion pour les ministres de
rencontrer des jeunes en apprentissage
et ils ont beaucoup parlé de leur
expérience d'apprentissage et sont
évidemment ravis de cette possibilité
d'être formés et cali su trouver un
emploi d'école c'est tout le l'enjeu de
l'apprentissage en 2019 la france
comptait 485 milles 800 apprentis soit
59 de plus qu'en 2018 ces nouveaux
dispositifs mis en place par le
gouvernement doivent donc permettre
d'augmenter encore le nombre d'apprentis
en france
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire vous le savez un
impact économique sans précédent d'où la
présentation en septembre dernier par le
gouvernement du plan en france relance
c'est une aide qui concerne également
l'industrie avec la mise en place d'un
fond d'accélération des investissements
industriels 150 millions d'euros
débloqué en 2020 à 400 millions d'ici
treize entreprises ont été sélectionnées
en ile de france dont quatre dans les
yvelines et parmi elle éblouit
industries and size installé aux loges
en josas le reportage de mélanie poker
et d'eléonore sinoquet houbloup
industrie crée des analyseurs de gaz
pour permettre à ses clients de limiter
leurs émissions polluantes et
d'améliorer leurs procédés de production
dans le cadre du plan de relance elle va
bénéficier de trois cent mille euros
ils vont servir
d'abord à faire des investissements de
matériel parce qu'on a on a besoin de
nouvelles technologies pour pouvoir
accélérer notre notre développement est
aussi de préparer le déménagement dans
de nouveaux locaux
ce qu'on va développer une nouvelle
unité de production pour pouvoir
fabriquer plus d'analyseurs et avoir un
rythme de production beaucoup plus
important des fonds qui lui permettront
aussi d'embaucher une vingtaine de
personnes
lancée en 2010 blue industrie lançons
premier analyseur en 2018
elle s'est portée candidate au fonds de
soutien à l'accélération de
l'investissement industriel
territoriales on cherche à ce type de
l'entreprise parce que on sait tous que
la période économique difficile que la
france est face à un défi qui est
considérable et il est temps maintenant
grâce au plan de relance de construire
l'économie de demain et l'économie de
demain elle aura une part industrielle
13 projets sont déjà lauréat dans la
région ile de france dont quatre dans
les yvelines
le fonds atteindra 400 millions d'euros
d'ici à 2022 pour parler de ce sujet
sophie primas est avec moi en
visioconférence bonsoir non
la sénatrice les républicains des
yvelines nous est également la
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques au sénat l'industrie a à
l'image de toute l'économie a été frappé
de plein fouet par la crise intégrer ce
fond d'accélération des investissements
et du industriel au sein de ce plan
france relancé ce que c'était une
nécessité selon vous et aussi quand on
sert toute la place de l'industrie si on
prend le focus sur le territoire des des
yvelines 20 % de l'emploi salarié est
industriel ce qui fait du département
des yvelines le plus industrialisé en
ile de france et est ce que c'était
nécessaire d'intégrer ce volet
industriel dans le plan france relance
je sais pas si c'était nécessaire de
l'intégrer dans le son de relance parce
que ça ça tient presque du bonneteau
budgétaire mais ce qui est important
c'est qu'on est un fonds qui soutiennent
l'industrie
on avait eu des initiatives de la part
du gouvernement et d'ailleurs des
gouvernements précédents tours
soutenir l'industrie et surtout la
transformation de l'industrie
je crois que c'est extrêmement important
qu'on dot ces fonds à la fois d'argent
sonnant et trébuchant mais aussi de
moyens en terme d'accompagnement pour
accélérer en fait la réindustrialisation
et la transformation de l'industrie
singulièrement dans notre département
mais partout en france on va parler des
montants dans un instant est ce que
d'après vous la reprise de l'économis ça
passe forcément par l'industrie la
reprise de l'économie passe aussi par
l'industrie pas que pas que ça il ya
d'autres secteurs d'activité je pense à
des industries auquel on pense pas
forcément mais qui ont des industries
par exemple agroalimentaire ou des
industries enfin mon commerce ou
d'autres doutent de lui ou les services
qui ont aussi besoin d'être modernisé
mais l'industrie c'est celle qui emploie
beaucoup de gens c'est celle qui a créé
de la valeur ajoutée sur le territoire
et c'est celle qui peut nous donner des
capacités exportatrices alors que on est
plutôt en retard aujourd'hui dans les
yvelines et singulièrement dans
l'honneur des evil qui est mon
territoire
l'industrie ça fait partie de notre de
notre adn
et c'est très important combien de cette
dimension industrielle mais il faut
absolument la moderniser et la
transformer en point vous le dites dans
leur désir et le long de la vallée de la
seine y en a aussi en matière
d'industrie dans la région de
rambouillet aussi de houdon 150 millions
d'euros en 2020 pour ce fonds
d'accélération des investissements
industriels 400 millions d'euros d'ici à
2022 avec quatre entreprises qui sont
pour le moment concernés dans les
yvelines est ce que les annonces du
gouvernement sont à la hauteur de vos
attentes et ce qu'il fallait encore
aller plus loin je pense que c'est pas
tellement une question de taille de
l'envelope budgétaire qui est annoncée
ce qui va être déterminant en réalité
c'est la capacité à dépenser cet argent
est dépensé très rapidement et à mettre
en place à la fois des hommes et des
méthodes visant à
simplification de l'installation et la
transformation industrielle
la clé c'est pas tellement la taille de
l'envelope pas de le répéter mais c'est
vraiment dans la façon dont on va
implémenter les décisions et faire en
sorte que cet argent irrigue rapidement
les entreprises qui en ont besoin
alors à côté de ce plan gouvernemental
la région ile-de-france a annoncé aussi
de son côté les détails de son programme
relance industrie destiné aux tpe pme
aux hôtes et industriels 75 entreprises
de la région ont été sélectionnés pour
obtenir ces aides en investissement
global de 42,5 millions d'euros parmi
elles 16 entreprises yvelinoise dont
deux sociétés saint-quentinoise engagés
dans la mécanique de précision regarder
ce sujet de nicolas d'andré de patrick
jacques de dixmude abl elle est
spécialisée dans l'industrie de
précision l'entreprise mécanique
ateliers de coignières fabrique des
pièces à partir de machines à commande
numérique
elle réalise plus de 80% de son activité
dans l'aéronautique impacté par la crise
sanitaire cette pme de 26 salariés à
décrocher une aide de la région
ile-de-france 450000 euros pour son
projet d'investissement
cette aide va nous permettre de
continuer à moderniser notre outil de
production à robotiser robotisée et
un digitalisées numériser toutes les
informations qu'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui et ont suivi de production
le but est de continuer la
diversification sur la partie clientèle
qu'on avait où on a une clientèle qui
était très 0 nautique et qui
malheureusement a été fortement impacté
avec la baisse du trafic aérien
et aujourd'hui on va essayer de se
reconvertir sur le secteur ferroviaire
ou aux militaires ou kate automobile
du côté de guyancourt la société gas
mika fabrique des pièces pour des
prototypes de l'industrie automobile et
pétrolières face à la crise et une
baisse d'activité entre 20 et 30%
cette entreprise a mis en place un prêt
garanti par l'état et reporter les
charges sociales et fiscales pour se
relancer elle souhaite investir 800
mille euros sur trois ans dont 350 mille
euros de subventions obtenues auprès du
conseil régional
alors notre axe c'est surtout de
développer tout ce que digital
puisqu'aujourd'hui on reçoit des plans
en 3d numérisés on les envoie sur nos
machines
donc on a encore des machines numériques
à acquérir on va essayer d'aller
chercher des marchés surtout ce que
l'hydrogène par rapport à tout ce qui
est moteur électrique également essayé
se redéployer sur tout ce qui est
médicale
spatiale est également tout ce que
défense au total dans le département des
yvelines 16 entreprises ont été
sélectionnées pour obtenir une
subvention de la région des projets
allant de la relocalisation d'activités
à la modernisation d'outils de
production une enveloppe globale de 10
millions 250 mille euros
sophie primas vous le disais il ya un
instant finalement le plus important
c'est pas le montant des enveloppes
c'est plutôt comment on va utiliser ces
différentes aides et on l'a vu dans les
deux sujets que nous avons proposé aux
téléspectateurs que finalement il ya
aussi un enjeu c'est aussi de moderniser
et moderniser l'industrie avec la
numérisation du tissu productif langage
est aussi dans la transition écologique
il faut sortir aujourd'hui de cette
image ancienne mais qui est forcément
phocéen elle a bien évolué et
l'industrie mais faut sortir de cette
image
bien sûr aujourd'hui l'industrie n'est
pas du tout l'industrie telle qu'elle
est dans l'imaginaire de certains je
crois qu industrie est en train de faire
un saut technologique comme peut-être
rarement elle a fait sinon à ses débuts
à la fois dans la conception de ce
qu'est l'industrie mais aussi dans la
production même de ce qu'est l'industrie
suffit d'aller se balader dans quelques
entreprises de daisy vinh pour
comprendre qu'on est plutôt dans une
industrie aujourd'hui en blouse blanche
en conception et en réalisations le
numérique bien sûr est à l'origine de
tout ça ça permet d'ailleurs à ces
entreprises on l'a entendu de vos
nouveaux sujets de trouver des pistes de
diversification qu'elles soient les
pistes de diversification sur les
produits qu'elle qu'elle qu'elle imagine
qu'elle sur lesquels elle innove avec
elle commercialise mais aussi c'est sur
des nouveaux marchés ou des nouveaux
segments et donc la digitalisation qui
est
l'avant de la numérisation il est à la
fois facteur de développement commercial
et facteur de meilleure compétitivité
donc c'est une industrie assez éloigné
de l'industrie un peu lourde un peu
salissante un peu bruyante dont on a
l'image en tête et l'autre enjeu cela
fait partie des objectifs de ce plan de
la région ile de france c'est aller vers
davantage de relocalisation de
l'activité en france il est nécessaire
d'après vous d'aller vers plus de made
in france à l'heure où l'on produit plus
volontiers dans les stades de l'europe
en asie notamment
bien sûr c'est tout l'enjeu je crois que
ça a été l'électrochoc de cette crise
même si on en était bien sûr persuadé
auparavant on a vu par exemple des
industries dans les yvelines de voir
pendant la crise s'arrêter parce qu'en
fait il y avait des éléments essentiels
à sa production qui manquaient pas ce
qu'ils venaient d'autres pays extérieur
donc je crois que la démarche qui
consiste qu'elle était d'ailleurs
préconisée par le gouvernement qui
consiste à identifier quels sont les
points clés quels sont les éléments
structurants quels sont les éléments qui
méritent à des notions de souveraineté
va nous permettre avec les efforts de
compétitivité de numérisation de
digitalisation qu'on est en train de
faire de retrouver en fait de la
compétitivité et de la sécurité en
matière de souveraineté industrielle là
donc je pense que c'est ces deux
éléments là qui sont qui sont clés à
l'un des sujets je voulais aborder avec
vous forcément lié à celui de
l'industrie celui de l'avenir du site
renault de flins sur seine qui concerne
directement votre commune où vous avez
été maire vous êtes maintenant
conseiller municipal de cette commune
aubergenville qui est limitrophe 1 de ce
site de renault flins la production de
véhicules neufs ça on l'a appris il ya
quelques mois renault et nissan micra
s'arrêter définitivement en 2024 sur
place l'usiné va être transformé en
refractory dédiée au recyclage et
reconditionnement des automobiles ça
c'est ce qui a été annoncé la semaine
dernière par la direction de la marque
au losange lors d'une visite sur place
l'objectif c'est d'employer en 2030 3000
personnes à flins le site compte
aujourd'hui 2500 salariés pour pour
précision est ce que ces annonces ont
nature à vous rassurer ce que c'est
encore trop flou et ce qu'il faut
attendre de voir ce qui va se passer
aussi dans les prochaines semaines je
crois que l'ambition du président un
scénar et du directeur général d'oc à di
meo essentiel est que notre objectif
c'est évidemment de garder de l'activité
sur le site de soin envers jean ville et
de permettre une transformation de ce
site vers autre chose
moi je jamais l'occasion plusieurs fois
de leur dire mon attachement à voir
sortir des voitures d'une chaîne de
production eon cela lisions un petit peu
répondu en disant qu'il y aura une
chaîne de production que celle de
reconditionnement des véhicules des
véhicules d'occasion avec autour tout un
projet assez bien packagée assez bien
marketé mais sur lequel on peut dire un
certain enthousiasme parce qu'on joue
qu'à di meo dit voilà il va y avoir un
nouveau marché sur le marché automobile
qui est le marché de la réutilisation
quel marché de la réutilisation à la
fois des véhicules de leur
transformation et la réutilisation des
pièces détachées pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas et on peut partager cet enthousiasme
moi je regrette toujours et encore et en
cela je n'ai pas tout à fait fini
d'essayer de réussir à faire changer un
petit peu renault de son fusil d'épaulé
je regrette que on ne fasse pas une
chaîne d'assemblage d'un véhicule neuf
c'est de l'adn de flins de cette usine
c'est l'adn des compétences des ouvriers
qui sont ici je ne fais pas encore mon
deuil de cet objectif-là je pense que
justement dans le cadre de territoire
dans des souris nous sommes territoire
d'industriels
fonds de relance du soutien en pga de
gouvernement apporte aharonot et bien il
faut continuer à travailler sur cette
hypothèse alors on nous a posé des
problèmes de compétitivité qu'on connaît
depuis très très longtemps sur ce site
de flins aubergenville mais je pense
qu'avec l'aide de collectivités
territoriales dans le cadre du plan de
relance
on peut travailler dans lequel de
l'industrie 4.0 à une hypothèse
d'assemblage en tout cas j'ai je n'ai
pas fait mon deuil et encore merci
sophie primas d'abord être avec nous
sénatrice les républicains des yvelines
les images pour terminer de ce gros
chantiers entamés dans les yvelines
celui de la rd30 rappelez-vous il a
débuté en 2015 et va se terminer début
2021 un plaisir après l'ouverture de la
circulation dès 2018 c'était la première
étape la dernière étape et la mise en
service d'une passerelle piétons et
vélos au niveau du bois de la crâne l
édifice a été posée la nuit dernière et
mélanie poquet a pu suivre les
manoeuvres 21h30 les hommes ferme
l'accès à une portion de la rd 30 entre
le giratoire des gâtines est celui du
petit saint cloud la circulation est
totalement coupée pour permettre
l'installation de la passerelle du bois
de la crâne est en fait la dernière
étape de cette opération qui consistait
à réaliser une passerelle pour les
piétons les cycles pour rétablir donc un
chemin de randonnée gr 11 donc et un
chemin qui va des stands où est donc
cette passerelle qui a été mise en place
cette nuit va servir effectivement à
rétablir cette circulation piétons et
cycles un ouvrage de 110 tonnes
assemblée sur le chantier installé grâce
à une grue géante la passerelle devrait
être accessible au public dans le
courant du premier trimestre 2011 21 il
va falloir être patient encore un petit
peu
il reste effectivement
des petits aménagements à faire donc eux
engourdi en béton donc pour pouvoir
circuler sur la passerelle et puis
aménager les rampes d'accès de part et
d'autre donc ça va prendre encore
quelques semaines
d'un coût de 80 7 millions d'euros
financés par le département et la région
ile de france
le chantier de la rd 30 à débuter en
il a permis de doubler la capacité de
cette route départementale en 2018
plus de trente mille véhicules
l'empruntent chaque jour et puis
transport toujours mais ferroviaire avec
le trafic du rer c qui pourraient être
interrompues pendant plusieurs jours
dans les yvelines
la nuit dernière vers 1h30 le coffrage
destinés à la réalisation d'une poutre
est tombée sur les voies au niveau du
quartier paris rive gauche
heureusement aucun blessé n'est à
déplorer mais une circulation est
totalement à l'arrêt notamment sur l'axé
saint quentin en yvelines versailles
chantiers dans un communiqué la sncf
indique ce mardi soir attendre des
précisions de la part des entreprises
responsables du chantier afin de
connaître la durée d'intervention
nécessaires pour retirer ce coffrage qui
pèse 4 tonnes des voix voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité demain mercredi vous
retrouverez eléonore sinoquet pour une
nouvelle édition belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]